[Music]
this farm has been passed down through
the family for a long time it's a part
of us it's a part of our family it's a
part of me it's a part of my kids so it
means a lot to us my great-grandfather
started and he had Hereford cattle back
in those days and cattle have always
been a part of this area in this farm
back in the early years cattle had their
places in the past year and they'd be
put in a pasture as the grazing season
began and that would be where they would
be at until it was time to come off and
I think now it's totally away from that
we start according to the grasses that
are available and indifferent and we're
gonna call them traps instead of
pastures now because we we've cut them
down into smaller acres we will graze
early season grasses earlier in the
spring and then the warm season grasses
during the summer time and then we go in
and start utilizing some aftermath
grazing and some cover crop grazing on
into the fall and maybe even into the
winter months
whether is a little in unpredictable up
here and I think everybody's getting a
lot more broad-minded about being able
to utilize not just the production of a
cereal grain crop but also the
byproducts that can be utilized from not
only the production of that crop but
opportunities for cover crop maybe after
that crops harvested and especially
useful when they enhance each other and
in the system where your corn wheat and
beans is your rotation you graze say you
plant a cover crop or even the residue
of say the corn and you're grazing your
cow herd out there increasing microbial
activity through the whole system to me
resilience longevity enters into that
quality of the environment and that goes
right along with water holding capacity
of the soil and microbial activity and
the soil and the production you're
getting off of it and still maintaining
the level of quality in the soil along
with also being a profitable entity for
the farm
[Music]
you